three ghosts and a time machine the
ending of better call saul didn't go
sci-fi on us but it does need some
explanation from that desperate escape
to the last cigarette here's everything
you need to know warning spoilers ahead
by better call saul's final episode
jimmy mcgill has lived under three names
and identities he starts as jimmy using
his birth name and is a hard-working
lawyer who seemingly can't resist a
shortcutter scheme he then becomes sol
goodman aiding and abetting the
murderous rise of drug kingpin walter
white finally we see him as gene takovic
the manager of a shopping mall cinnabon
who lives in constant fear of his
previous identities being discovered the
final episode sol gone gives each of
them the ending they deserve gene
takovic died as he lived hiding from the
police in a literal dumpster after
months of hiding in omaha buried under a
thick mustache and even thicker glasses
gene dips his toe back into the grifter
life after being recognized by
dim-witted taxi driver jeff however the
erstwhile slipping jimmy doesn't do
anything halfway his schemes become
riskier his true self comes through a
little too much and before long his
cover is completely blown by jeff's
youtube savvy mother marion played by
comedy legend carol burnett the final
four episodes in the series primarily
take place in the gene takavic era this
came as something of a surprise to
co-creator vince gilligan who told
rolling stone we were fascinated by
jimmy mcgill and then we wanted to see
more of gene takovic and omaha so we
kind of ran out the clock without even
meaning to and then we realized man the
first thing that could go was saul
goodman and that's the name of the show
it's only fitting that a man who was
once so good at elder law would finally
be brought to justice by an elder
much like gus spring gene is both a
career criminal and a steadfast and
reliable fast food employee even while
he's in the custody of the omaha police
gene uses his phone call to contact
cinnabon and let his staff know that he
won't be coming in ever again
this is how they get you
this is how they get you
facing in his holding cell like an
animal gene is furious with himself
after working as a cartel lawyer for
years he is finally caught because of a
small-time identity theft scheme lying
on the cold floor he glances up at a
crude carbon on the cell wall that says
my lawyer will ream your ass like a
switch being flipped gene takovic dies
and saul goodman is reborn gould who
wrote the script revealed that he views
jean saul and jimmy as three very
separate characters telling rolling
stone since this is an episode where he
goes from gene to saul and eventually
back to jimmy i was pretty careful to
use the name that felt right at every
moment i called those moments out in the
script
after months of hiding from the world
saul goodman returns the world's
greatest lawyer finds himself sitting at
a table across from a battalion of
hardened federal attorneys who are ready
to put him away for life plus 190 years
for working with walter white at his
side is bill oakley his favorite public
defender punching bag turned defense
attorney but only as an advisor saul
represents himself and his defense is a
doozy with pleading eyes and a trembling
voice he tells the collected prosecutors
that he worked for walter white under
fear of death lead prosecutor george
castellano asks if saul really thinks a
jury will believe his story saul
shrewdly responds
all i need is one
the scene reflects what many thought the
show would be from the beginning playing
on the character's comic relief and his
penchant for legal chicanery better call
saul did have plenty of that but few
expected jimmy mcgill to be such an
emotionally rich character least of all
the actor playing him in an interview
with the los angeles times bob odenkirk
described the start of his journey
playing the character saying so that
makes me as a beginning actor really
have to dig up a lot of stuff and feel a
lot of feelings from my own life in a
visceral way that left me feeling pretty
shagged out and ragged
the scene where saul lays out his victim
angle isn't all fun and games of course
saul is on the hook for money laundering
bribery and being an accessory after the
fact that dozens of murders including
those of hank trader and steve gomez on
hand to represent those victims is
hank's wife marie schrader played by
betsy brandt the pain of hank's death
clearly still weighs on marie and she
delivers a devastating monologue about
her husband saul's use of her real pain
to pivot into his own false narrative is
one of his most callous moments in the
entire series
they tell me they found you in a garbage
dumpster
well that makes sense
this was brandt's first appearance on
better call saul and her first time
playing marie since he ended breaking
bad nine years earlier she joined
several returning guest stars in the
finale including brian cranston as
walter and michael mckean is jimmy's
brother chuck when asked if there were
any other actors or characters from the
better call saul and breaking bad
universe he wanted to bring back for the
finale ghoul's answer was essentially
everyone as he told rolling stone i
would have loved to have patrick fabian
back to have dean norris back and a gun
would have been great if it fit in the
story i love our entire cast i'm greedy
we didn't want to make a kind of
overstuffed epic and i hope we didn't
just as saul returns to the law on his
own behalf so does kim first she
delivers her notarized confession to the
district attorney and howard's widow
cheryl hamlin in the penultimate episode
waterworks then she returns to her
purposely bland indecisive life in
central florida still the active
confession has changed something in kim
and she takes a tentative step forward
in her life by turning up at a legal aid
office kim's fate has been a driving
question for the series and its fans
from the very beginning kim was one of
the few main characters who did not
appear in breaking bad and many fans
feared the worst thinking kim might be
killed by the cartel however creator
peter gould told rolling stone that it
was important that kim's journey was her
own and not simply a detail in the jimmy
mcgill story
in the finale saul returns to an
albuquerque courtroom once again wearing
an outlandish suit viewers presume some
big twist is coming that saul has a
final stunt to pull and that he might
not end up serving the seven and a half
year sentence he fled down to there is
indeed a twist coming but not one that
anyone would have guessed saul begins
the hearing which is supposed to be a
formality to ratify his plea deal by
retelling the story of meeting walter
white for the first time fearing for his
life out in the desert then he stops and
for once tells the truth he kept working
for walt for 16 blood-soaked months
because he smelled money the scene also
invokes jimmy's emotional speech in
front of the bar association at the end
of season 4 which got his law license
reinstated and inflicted saul goodman
upon the world in both cases he is
playing to his audience using his real
emotions to affect the desired outcome
but this time it's an audience of one
and that's kim i just wanted her to come
here today i wanted her to hear this
interspersed with the main story of
three flashbacks to earlier times in
both better call saul and breaking bad
during these moments an important
question is considered
what would you do if you had a time
machine
a time machine
the first flashback takes us to the
season five episode bagman when jimmy
and mike face a harrowing two days in
the mexican desert hauling seven million
dollars in cash for lalo salamanca's
bail saul also poses the question to
walter white as the two of them await
being whisked away by ed the vacuum
repairman and the scene that takes place
during the breaking bad episode granite
state i'm lucky month from now best case
scenario i'm managing a cinnabon in
omaha gould revealed that he wanted the
flashbacks to show how jimmy is making a
change at long last telling rolling
stone the feeling i had about this
episode was that it was a little bit
like a christmas carol gene becomes saul
and he's visited by three ghosts and
each time he's visited by one of these
ghosts you realize this guy is trapped
in the cycle
while speaking to others jimmy's answers
to the time machine question are shallow
and facile but his real answer is found
in the episode's third flashback a
moment from the very beginning of better
call saul as jimmy delivers groceries to
his brother chuck chuck has taken a
leave of absence from the law firm he
founded with howard hamlin's father due
to a debilitating sensitivity to
electromagnetic waves in this moment of
brotherly kindness chuck makes a small
effort to reach out to jimmy but the
future saul goodman doesn't bite leaving
chuck to read hg wells as the time
machine by himself in the dark as much
as the relationship between jimmy and
kim has come to define the series for
the first three seasons his relationship
with chuck was arguably more important
in an interview with the los angeles
times odenkirk said of jimmy he's a guy
who is showing the audience his need his
hunger for love and respect from his
brother chuck his heart is open to chuck
and chuck crushes him it's impossible
not to wonder how different jimmy's life
would have been had his brother still
been alive
jimmy's truth-telling stunt gets him 86
years in prison but it turns out that
the prison isn't such a bad place for
saul goodman to end up
for one everyone calls him saul and he
gets fist bumps as he walks through the
halls he even gets to nurture his gene
takavik side by baking bread in the
prison cafeteria according to gould this
was always the natural end point for
jimmy as he told rolling stone this guy
has lived in the justice system he's
made a farce of it he's played it and it
just felt like that was the right place
to end the series him behind bars
jimmy may be behind bars but he's not
alone and kim even visits him posing as
his lawyer the two lean up against the
back wall of the room and share a
cigarette it's a quiet intimate scene
that evokes the scene the couple shared
in the pilot episode the cigarette burns
in color against the scene's film noir
inspired black and white filter
appropriately this was the final scene
that ray seahorn and bob odenkirk filmed
together and it's both the characters
and the actors saying goodbye after the
episode aired seahorn told vulture oh
what a great gift when your own emotions
match up with what your character is
supposed to be feeling
hi jimmy
the saga ends with a wistful look and a
pair of finger guns from behind bars as
kim leaves jimmy to serve his 86 year
sentence jimmy mcgill goes out on his
own terms atoning for his crimes and
closer to the woman he loves and he has
been in years still better call saul
leaves the audience with many questions
for instance will cheryl go through with
her plan to suit kim for her role in
howard's death i could sue you in civil
court i could take everything you've got
is jesse doing better on alaska than
gene did in omaha is this really the
last time jimmy and kim will see each
other will jimmy accept his prison fate
so easily or will the old slip and jimmy
come creeping up and are jimmy's enemies
dead or is there some associate of the
salamancas but is still out there with a
thirst for revenge we may never know the
answers to these questions but it was
still one hell of a finale
[Music]